this isn't just a raid it's a rescue
mission
one of hundreds that have taken place
across the Philippines in the last few
years
agents racing to a family home believed
to be the scene of a vile betrayal a
mother accused of selling her own kids
to perform sexually on webcams for
pedophile simmer this illegal activities
are increasing in numbers so probably
the victims would be thousands thousands
of children yeah what you can hear the
cries of children just rescued the
calling out for their mother who's been
arrested since this children are groomed
as as young as 1 year old
okay so they thought that what they are
doing are just normal you always see
this children crying and as if they're
they haven't or their parents haven't
committed anything wrong to them after
being rescued children are taken to
shelters like this the Center for Hope
run by the Visayan Forum charity around
fifty girls are here all have suffered
unspeakable abuse don't know when your
name again Dan up on topic Wooden Nickel
poem noggin on young girls Avenue open
up our apnea Casa Rivera any pitcher in
Yahoo Nava who bad the post the
Langham's a bottom and over perimeter my
customers Iberico cylinder emerald o
America London Australia waiver for
tapas new su mamá papá Sonya then Ellen
opposed our new computer
that was my own private room that's been
a subpoena power cord
there's no [ __ ] possible for Merrill
paavana patanki but upon my backup
Winona come back my toughest out of no
Chimaera this 13 year old was rescued 12
months ago she'd been abused for years
did you know when you were 8 years old
and nine years old that what was
happening was wrong that the men who
were asking you to do these things were
were bad people the vulnerability of
these girls isn't just down to what
they've been through but also the
testimony they may be able to give to
secure convictions so the security here
is tight they cannot leave even to
continue their education parts of this
Center feel quite like a school there's
a classroom just there there's been
activities in the hall and through this
door is a nursery but the thing you have
to remember is that this isn't a school
at all it's a refuge and the children
small enough to sit on these seats have
been taken away from their communities
and their families because this is the
only place there seem to be safe but as
well as providing safety social workers
and schooling this place nurtures
shattered lives are slowly being rebuilt
and yet the work is never complete the
charities resources are stretched to the
limit because new girls are arriving
almost every week we have girls who come
here as young as one year old and I gosh
it's it's for me it's as a matter also
it's clearly you know break my heart to
see this little girl very thin sick but
already damaged
you know I tried to hide my emotion
without talking to them but when I go
back home I really cry my heart because
I understand talking to these young
girls you know seeing them how she how
broken they are how traumatize the arts
it's an acceptable and acceptable but
the truth is things are getting worse
it's now a widespread phenomenon the
violence the abuse of the children on
the Internet is getting more and more
extreme in an effort to tackle this
Dutch charity Terre des hommes believes
more must be done to stem the demand and
that demand is extraordinary this isn't
the dark web it's a public chat room the
investigator is posing as an 11 year old
Filipino child she's getting a lot of
attention it's almost impossible to keep
up with that's why this charity has
developed a piece of software called
sweetie my name is windy
I'm ten years old I live in the
Philippines every day I have to sit in
front of the webcam and talk to men but
what they don't know
I'm not real I'm a computer model the
latest version of this automated chat
bot has become increasingly
sophisticated it communicates with and
gathers the data of hundreds of
pedophiles automatically so here this is
a guy who says he's 20 from the UK yeah
and we can see that the bot here has
said hi I'm deysi 10 from the
Philippines yes so that person has shown
an interest to have a webcam a show on
the vet on the webcam and he knows I'm a
sexual as far as he's concerned that
this is a ten year old girl from indeed
indeed that's the first red flag yes
it's not a problem for me that you're
only ten years old
and then this restates it right you mind
you don't mind that I'm Ted's actly to
any precise to emphasize the fact that
hey I'm only ten is this a problem for
you and the moment the person says no
it's not a problem then the red flag
goes on the aim is for this tool to be
used by law enforcement agencies
enabling them to send warning messages
as a deterrent it's no silver bullet but
it's a start
once you remove that blanket of
anonymity and to say hey but I know who
you are and I know what you want and do
you know that this is a crime against
minors that you are thinking of
committing then you will have that
chocolate back
[Music]
but perhaps seeing the real-world
consequences should shock people - these
girls are in the process of healing from
a very 21st century trauma thousands
more are at this very moment still being
subjected to it
Tom Rayner Sky News Manila